you tandis que ce qui s'est passé bandel
liberté aujourd'hui je trouve sur
attaquant petite entrevue de games l'a
tirée du manga attaque en quittant on
peut jouer au moins un gars si vous
voulez mais ça risque d'être un peu
moins drôle la page 28
lorsque soudainement il se retourne ses
parties multijoueurs la [ __ ] adjoint
tito et on se déplace de manière très
sexuel au wat
à terme elle lui fait dix points
bataille quoi c'est un méga titan moi je
peux mourir si j'ai tué ou [ __ ] j'ai
défoncé à [ __ ] un coup de vent comme
ça je vous dis ça fait très mal quand
ils doivent me tuer moi je dois les tuer
et pour me tuer eux il faut qu'ils qui
me met un coup d'épée dans la nuque
voilà sinon c'est ils arriveront pas me
tuer là par exemple il vient de réussir
les [ __ ]
regardez les lacets petit ninja là
qu'est ce qu'on veut sauter mais oui pas
qu'un pot sa compagne onu comme moi ah
tu regardes le mur ont rien lui ensemble
ouais bon domus compagnie trop bizarre
quatuor va se faire je vous jure presse
de faire là bas via la petite fourmi il
se croit en sécurité mais il ne l'est
pas mais non attendez on se fait
celui-là en attendant vous toucherez pas
manu [ __ ] non aïeux à hilla lui a fait
mal aux yeux il m'a fait mal aux yeux je
peux plus voir les faux qui mène mon
copain et deux mois il s'est fait choper
le téton et les tout-petits oui c'est un
bébé titan lâchez nous voilà je crois
qu'il est décédé
eye-fi vidéos youtube ou facebook arrive
en dortoir à il est mort je crois qu'il
est bien décédé
oui effectivement ce sens indique que
soit il est décédé wife et ils jouent
très bien qu'on me dit très très bien
regarder le lui keita pong et à titan
pourquoi je suis petit comme ça c'est
aléatoire puisque je dois est un titre
aléatoire il doit vers différents types
de titan hyatt à melwood
il vient vers moi et merde [ __ ] une
fois et il a pris la petite ruelle
sombre mais ils sont fous n'a pas tort
il va voir lesquels ici des gens par les
airs aïe
mais non mais je suis avec toi jeune
homme partage peut pas passer il est
trop gros non il a tu as un choc pour
moi je n'ai rien pu faire faut que tu
est lui bloqué sur made you put
attention et des mois oui merci les gars
merci je peux me regarder
ouais j'suis boissons
son pénis quoi mais je le regarde et
attend mais le mec il passe en dessous
nous allons et l'habitat et la bouffe
est quoi sans déconner il ya un bébé
titan blow mg je meurs c'est moi le bébé
titan blonde tu te calmes aux élus que
même les gens ils se moquent de mon
titre
allez on y va les enfants à temps mais
ces choix s'accrocher aux branches
enrichi accroché à lui regardez-moi ça
vous lui l'hélicoptère mais bien le
bordel mais attends mais je vais lui
coupe est et où il n'ya pas comprendre
au pénis c'est fini je comprends plus
rien oh [ __ ] olmèques saloperie de
titan et [ __ ] non c'est fait dix est
payé en gros plan bordel regardez je les
fais mal aux yeux là je vais derrière
dans son cou dans la baie des foetus au
plein au plat voilà au plat comme je
disais oui j'en ai regardé regardez
comme c'est beau up by bouge pas donc
c'est plus pratique
voilà un petit coup d'arrêt du cas
bientôt on l'a agrippé on lâche plus bas
lui non plus il nous a pas lâchés au jeu
la grippe et à non mais pourquoi
toujours le zizi on va mettre la map
colossal du temps avec cazes [ __ ] de
joueurs savent être l'anarchie attention
là c'est un [ __ ] de gros il fait très
mal aux quais aux tissus damassés ses
collègues mortel au repas pour pas plus
attention à ce stade il faut fuir
ok ça où j'ai réussi à m'enfuir
peut-être un peu trop loin tallom
j'encourage quoi je m'enfuis il est
incroyable ce titan et comment on fait
on tuer ses chats jallet la pâte y ait
des gens regardez tout viol ou pas de
titan cheon
ok on change voilà non je pars à je te
dis en mon cas ah ok c'est un très gros
titan quoi en bas un très gros titan
décédé apparemment allée guest on est
tous avec toi tu es le dernier suivant
comme toujours à l'orgue est haye
tu prend des claques attendait il s'en
sort bien il se sent bien le coup annie
qu'elle en avait marre là de la manger
tiens jeune femme joue plus bien là je
comprends rien à ce qui se passe au bout
d'un élastique surpris de ma vie aussi
ah ben voilà bah là j'ai vraiment beau
de ma vie maintenant mon dieu laissez
prendre un caillou faut stopper mais on
peut pas et après en fait c'est ça qui
est problématique ce qu'on fait avec lui
les gars alors déjà voilà voilà tout le
tapage pendant qu'on se pose une
question est ce fait du gros plan sa
nuque
[ __ ] d'enfoirés 2 non désolé c'est pas
moi c'est pas à plat dans les yeux et
ses deux caméras elle est folle quoi
jamais une caméra monsieur ries je suis
je là comme un dangereux elle fait ça
c'est incroyable quoi me contacter à map
ta phut voilà deux mois ton petit coup
maintenant bat est décédé voilà on a eu
honte a eu 3 v 1 c'était fair play en
plus balade à base de viande au moins tu
sais que j'ai des chefs de gang on est
tous contre toi voilà gens dans ta
bouche qu'est ce qui est à moi je suis
dentiste pour titan mon gars viala au
mondial on a eu un chai pas comment on a
eu un bordel mon dieu oh mon dieu on
avait su brosser le trophée là what you
gonna do when we call me i'll milano six
ans plus tard tournée avait son grappin
sur sa nuque le pauvre comme si avec ce
projet ça la burqa du québec je vais tu
joues et tu les gardes parce que vous
savez pourquoi je suis forte parce que
ce n'est pas de boost voilà c'était ma
blague à bientôt
je n'ai plus dp je fais l'animation
comme si on sortait de nouvelles mais ne
sont pas là tuez moi alors je suis vous
pouvez le tuer parce que là je vois des
zizis mais je vois pas de morale à voilà
merci là nous il n'a rien vu venir
belle surprise mois de boeck est ce qui
s'est passé dans les yeux dans les yeux
et m'a bouffé en plein auplata aveugle
et c'est pas possible des techniques
spéciales je lui trouve les yeux mbu
papa des petits qui nous ont bouffées 26
fois alors vous n'avez pas m'atteindre
ont été de [ __ ] de requins claque la
nuque en place
alors ça fait bobo bah oui la situation
mais regardez-moi ça la tête à coups de
pied qui va se perdre mais regardez
couach est encerclé par quatre et j'ai
plus dp vous avez gagné haut la main qui
fait presque bataille c'est un peu
millions pour un titan n'est ce pas un
seul millions raté c'est encore plus
humiliant d'un coup un peu tué tapis
dans la nuque derrière tape une
diversion aubin alors il faut wima
l'agencé dia besoin de céder 2 /
attaquant petit en tribu games sas vous
a plu et si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas
aimé la vidéo ou à mettre des coudrais
luchetti temps comme vous voulez j'ai
vraiment eu besoin de dix ans sur ce jeu
parce qu'il ya une version du jeu qui
était sorti il ya très longtemps il me
semble je sais pas si on pouvait jouer
en ligne
en tout cas là je viens de marquer une
nouvelle version qui sortit c'est celle
ci et j'en ai profité pour y jouer ces
nouveaux frais pas là alors se retrouver
dans une nouvelle vidéo merci d'avoir
gardé tout le monde
oh
m
[Musique]